[APPLAUSE]
ANDREAS PREUER: Hi,
my name is Andreas,
and I'm a partner development
manager at Google Play.
In my day-to-day job I work
with the most interesting
mobile game developers in
North America and Europe.
There are many familiar
faces, actually,
in here-- quite exciting.
And I hope to help
actually developers
on making their mobile games
business successful on Google
Play.
TOBIAS KNOKE: Hi,
my name is Tobias.
I'm a partner a development
manager based in London
and working with developers
in Western Europe.
Today, at the first session
after the lunch break,
we want to help you
to promote your game
and to grow your user base.
But before talking about the
key essentials for your user
acquisition strategy, we would
like to put this into context.
As you heard earlier before,
the mobile industry is growing.
And it's getting more
competitive, as well.
There are more than 10
million developers worldwide,
and each year they publish
more than one million apps.
And if you look on the right
side, if you think about games,
the lifecycle of games
has shortened as well
over the past years.
In 2012, the average
game matured after a bit
more than 150 weeks.
Last year, it was a
bit less than 50 weeks.
So you have a competitive
market, shorter life cycles,
and also increasing
production values.
And this means you want to have
your user acquisition strategy
as effective as possible.
ANDREAS PREUER:
Today we will cover
three key examples for your
user acquisition strategy.
First I will talk about how you
can better understand your paid
and organic traffic,
then second, Toby
will show you how to convert
with effective channels,
and third, Toby and Andrew will
talk about how to engage users
in a social platform.
Let me kick it off
with understanding
your paid and organic traffic.
You can find a conversion funnel
in the Google Play Developer
Console.
The conversion funnel shows
you Play Store visitors,
installers, and bias
by acquisition channel
you can also see the
relevant conversion rates
and you can drill down
on search keywords
and UTM track channels to
better understand where
your users are coming from.
You can also find a country
breakdown of Google Play's
conversion funnel.
You can drill into performance
in your key markets
and learn about
underperforming markets.
If you learned [INAUDIBLE]
the installer's conversion
rate in a specific market
is below your expectations,
you can take action and improve
the localized store listing.
You can then launch a
store listing experiment
to test your updated
store listing
to get more game installs.
However, optimizing your
business strategy in isolation
is not that helpful.
So let's look back at store
listing organic conversion
rates.
How do you know if
your conversions are
as good as they can be,
or you're leaving actually
an opportunity on the table?
At Google I/O, we've
announced benchmarking
against your peers.
This feature is coming soon
to Google Play's developer
console, and you are
now able to understand
how your store
listing conversion
rate compares to similar games.
First, we are providing
an overall benchmark
for your organic users.
And then we also, actually,
provide a country breakdown
that helps you to understand
how your game is actually
performing versus the
benchmark in a specific market.
If you understand that
your game is potentially
underperforming in
a specific market,
you can actually take action
based on this insight.
So here you can see one example.
And the game is
actually performing OK,
but it could do better.
So you can actually optimize
the localization of the store
listing and prove
the performance of it
and get much better results.
If you want to understand
users even better
than what you've seen
actually in the conversion
funnel in the play store
and the developer console,
you can actually use
Firebase Analytics.
It was touched upon actually
earlier in the presentation.
And Firebase
Analytics for mobile--
there's a couple things for you.
So first, it's actually entirely
free and it is unlimited.
You are able to actually
measure 500 different event
types and 25 key
value pairs per event.
You're also able to access
unlimited, unsampled data
through [INAUDIBLE].
Firebase is very
much user centric.
So you can actually focus on
users instead of sessions.
And then you will
also see metrics
that are meaningful for
you as a game developer.
So you will see actually
daily active user stats,
but you will also see, for
example, LTV stats that you
can use for optimization.
I've just seen my
colleague walking in.
He will talk later a little bit
more about LTV optimisation.
Firebase helps you to
already get these stats.
And this is full right
baked into Firebase.
Firebase is also well integrated
with other Google products,
so it is integrated
with our ads product,
with our notifications
product, and you can easily
target audiences that
have actually captured
with Firebase on other things.
It is also very easy to actually
track any user acquisition
campaigns through any paid
channels that you have.
You can see here a
couple of partners
that are integrated
with Firebase,
and you can then actually
attribute your ads band,
and you can understand,
is it actually
a good way to invest in one
of the channels, or is it
a better way to actually
invest in the other channels.
And so by implementing
Firebase you will actually
get all of this data, and
you can take action right
after that.
So now we talked about
how to understand
your paid and organic traffic.
Let's move on and talk
about how you can convert
with effective channels.
Earlier today, Mark referenced
a number of installs
on Google Play.
Last year we had 65
billion installs.
And at the Play Store,
we matched the best users
with the best content.
We want personalized
collections,
and offer seasonal
collections as well.
But the vast
majority of installs
still comes from search.
There are more than
one billion users
on Google Play, and
more than 190 countries,
as you know already.
And all these users search.
On google.com, there
are each month more
than 100 billion searches.
So you cannot only achieve
success by reaching the users
on google.com, but
also on the Play Store.
Let's have a look at an example.
This is a store listing
of War and Order,
and the developer decided to
do search ads on google.com.
That's something you
might be familiar with.
A user searching for a
strategy game and both
paid and organic
results are shown.
But also, as you can
see on the right side,
you can do the same
in the Play Store.
Both organic and paid
results are shown.
So the best way of
executing this campaign
is working with a tool.
Who here in the audience
has heard about the key word
tool for add words?
Some people have.
So if you're wondering what are
the best keywords for my Play
Search ads campaign,
we have a keyword tool
which helps you to get the right
keywords for your mobile game.
Keywords are very important
to optimize your campaign
day by day, and we encourage
you to use this tool
to optimize your campaigns
for the Play Store.
So now you might ask yourself,
OK, now I go back home
and try it out.
But will that work?
Well, we have one example
here from Nordeus,
the developers of Top Eleven.
I'm actually a big Top Eleven
addict and my team knows that.
But these guys use
the play search ads,
and they achieve the highest
seven day [INAUDIBLE],
68% higher than other
Google channels.
And also the play search
ads, compared to google.com--
they were 59% lower
in terms of the CPI.
So I encourage you to
try this out at home.
Don't forget the
three best practices.
One, use the keyword tool,
two, run target CPA campaigns
and ensure that the CPA is
lower than your lifetime value,
and last but not least, optimize
the campaigns day by day.
Because with an
advertising campaign,
it's basically like
with a mobile game--
it's never finished.
So now we talked
about understanding
your paid and organic
traffic, converting these guys
with effective channels.
But the players, if they're
not playing your game,
they are actually
on social platforms.
They are talking
about your game.
They are watching
videos about your game.
And the number one social
platforms for games is YouTube.
95% of all gamers turn to
YouTube for information
and entertainment.
Gamers watch 144 billion
minutes every month
on YouTube for live videos,
recorded videos, and streams.
So actually somebody
calculated that number.
Now, the real stars on
YouTube are the influencers.
Who here in the audience has
worked with YouTube influencers
before?
OK, I see-- wow, a lot of hands.
More than the key word tool.
All right.
So please raise your hand
again if you were successful.
That's quite good, but I think
we can increase the conversion
rate a bit more.
You see some examples
here on the slide.
So on the top
right, you see KSI.
That's one at the top
YouTubers in the UK,
14.5 million subscribers.
You see ConCrafter, a very
popular YouTuber in Germany.
LDShadowLady is the most
popular of female gamer
on YouTube, with more than
2.5 million subscribers.
And last but not least, gamers
in France turned to [INAUDIBLE]
to learn more about the latest
games and updates and let's
play videos.
So these are some examples.
But now you might ask yourself,
OK, what is the right strategy?
What are the YouTubers I
should be working with,
and how does success look like?
So we thought we should ask
someone who knows it best.
Please welcome with me, Andrew
Stalbow, the CEO of Seriously.
ANDREW STALBOW: Hey, there.
I'm Android Stalbow, CEO
and co-founder at Seriously.
We've got one app currently
out in the market called
Best Fiends, and I'm
going to talk a little bit
today about our
marketing strategy, which
is primarily focused on
YouTube and influencers.
And I'm also going to
share a little short video
at the end, which shows how
we are planning on taking
our work to the next level.
So our approach is
to build a brand.
We look at the app that
we have and the apps
that we have coming
as the platform
for our intellectual property.
We think it's a great
opportunity right now,
with everybody moving from
traditional media platforms
to new devices obviously,
like mobile tablets,
for entertainment brands
to be directly connected
to their audience.
One of the great challenges the
traditional media industry have
is that the IP is
normally distributed
on someone else's platform
other than the creators.
And we thought by
being connected
we might have an opportunity to
build up our IP in a big way.
We try to be as creative
in our marketing
as we are in our
product development.
Our apps are about introducing
a world and characters
and a story to the market.
And when we were thinking about
how we can be super creative,
we knew that as a small
early stage startup,
it would be really,
really hard to compete
with the massive marketing
budgets of some of the biggest
players in the app stores.
And so we asked when we
launched, when we launched Best
Fiends, coming up
to two years ago,
we asked the CEOs
of most mobile game
companies, what works for you?
And everyone said, Facebook,
Twitter, great acquisition
platforms.
And we said, what doesn't work?
And they all said, YouTube.
I can't make YouTube
work for acquisition.
So we thought that we'd
really focus there.
And over the last
few months, we've
been super focused on taking
our approach on YouTube
as upper level, really
focused on US-UK as kind
of core markets
for us, and we've
had some really
interesting learnings.
So we'll share some
of those with you.
Our strategy is based on the
app being a live service.
So every two to three
weeks we update our app
with some fun new product
features, new content,
new levels, new characters,
enhance the experience,
and we mirror the product update
with big marketing pushes.
We've actually got one today.
On average, we're looking
to hit somewhere between 70
and over 150 videos over a
weekend that kind of help
promote our game.
Today we've got an update where
we're introducing a treasure
hunt into our game.
It's a really popular
feature with our audience
where if you find 15 stickers
that we've hidden in the game,
you get to unlock a new
fiend, Terry the Tarantula.
You can otherwise
buy him for $10,
or you can win him by
finding all the stickers
in the next three weeks.
Each of those stickers comes
from a famous YouTube star.
And over the next few
days, these YouTubers,
including Rachel
Levin, Rosanna Pansino,
are going to run a
video saying, hey, find
my sticker in the game.
And if you find all of them from
all these other YouTube stars
as well, you unlock
the character.
Which is really nice to be
able to kind of integrate
your marketing message
with the product itself.
So overall as a company, we've
got two million daily players.
But over the last
three or four months
when we realized that we
could scale this up in the US,
we've be making some
really nice progress.
We're now around
450 thousand DAU
since we started focusing on
a big influence of strategy.
And if I look at our
progress that we've made,
we really kind of shifted
our DAU from a year ago.
And you can see that
we've kind of really
started building our base in
the US, which is now our biggest
market.
So here are some
of the key lessons
that we've learned from
working with influencers.
You know, what I'd say is this
is what we've learned so far,
but the market is
always changing.
And now it's getting more
and more competitive.
I saw like 80% of you have done
work with YouTube influencers.
I think the trick is,
take this, but you've
got to kind of be more
creative than what we've done.
Because the things
always moving.
And I think it's really, really
important to try and outdo
what you've done before
So the number one thing
we kind of learned
is, YouTubers are
brands themselves.
They're connected
to their audience.
They like working
with other brands.
And if you haven't got a
brand vision for your product,
you should really
think about that
in terms of how you
communicate with a YouTuber,
because that's what will
get them very excited.
The second thing is, most
big brands as we know them,
most big, big brands tend
to be very, very detailed
about what they're looking for
for the YouTuber to do or say.
The reality is,
that doesn't work.
You've got to let the
YouTuber be authentic.
They've got a genuinely
like your product,
and if they don't, I don't
think it's a good fit.
So it's really important
they like your product,
and that you allow them
to be very authentic.
And when I say integrate
back in for maximum effect,
the example is that
treasure hunt today.
I think it's a really
nice way of kind
of allowing them to say, hey, I
enjoy the experience of playing
the game, or playing the app.
And there's a reason why
you can find something
from me in there.
These guys have amazingly
close relationships
with their audience,
and they've got
to feel natural and authentic.
Working with big guys is
great, because it sets you up
in the marketplace and allows
other influences to come in
and say, oh, I'd like to
work with you because KSI
worked with you.
I'll tell you a funny
story about our very, very
first experience working
with an influencer.
When we launched we
worked with PewDiePie.
It was like, our launch
had a very small budget.
We put most of it into
a PewDiePie video.
And we definitely learned
some lessons there.
But I'd say it's
really important
to work with some
of the big guys that
allows you to focus on some of
the new up and comers as well.
What I love about YouTube as
a platform and influence is,
generally, is that many,
many of these views
are occurring on mobile.
So if you're trying to kind
of deliver nice acquisition
and build your
business, you're always
one click away from a download.
And I think that's what makes
the platform so powerful.
And you know, we've tried loads
of things in our marketing.
I really encourage our
team to think creatively
about trying new stuff
that we can learn from.
And what's incredible
about this platform is,
unlike, say, a television
buy, or a one-day kind
of digital media activation,
the video is live.
And you'll carry on doing views.
We go back to videos that we
did at the start this year,
and they've added another
half a million views.
So it's not ephemeral
like television.
So I think it's a really,
really interesting platform
to focus on.
The other thing you get
is, you get a long tail,
you get, in theory,
an endorsement
if the YouTuber
likes your product.
But the other thing you
get as well, in addition,
is media value on top.
You reach a big audience.
And for us, as a company,
that is valuing the brand
that we're trying to build and
looking to build value there.
Actually kind of
putting this out there,
you get to see that
you're even more
effective across other
acquisition channels, too.
So one of the things
we're starting to look at
is how this also helps
with our retention as well
as acquisition.
You know, it's really important
that if you are working
with an influencer, they
are upfront, honest,
straightforward about
what you're doing.
There are certain
rules that you need
to comply with in
different markets,
but at the end of the day,
the kind of golden rule
is, just be straightforward.
If you're paying
an influencer, they
need to make sure that they
do mention that very clearly.
So today we're actually
launching a video that kind of
takes the evolution of the
700 or so YouTube influencer
videos we've done, and
takes it to the next level.
And really, the way we
kind of think about it is,
we've been building
our two million DAU
and 40 plus million downloads
on the back of other people's
influence of videos.
And we think that's a
really nice strategy
and we're going to carry
on working on that.
But we wondered if there was a
way that we could kind of take
that to the next level.
So what we're launching
today is a scripted video
that will be working very
hard on for quite a few months
now, where we integrate
traditional Hollywood talent,
in this case Kate Walsh, who
was in the television show
"Grey's Anatomy," [INAUDIBLE],
and appeals to our core
audience demographic of
25 to 45-year-old women,
and marrying that with
two of the world's biggest
YouTube stars,
Rosanna Pansino, who's
the biggest kind of
celebrity chef on YouTube,
and Joey Graceffa, who's very,
very popular, particularly
within the LGBT
community, and marrying
those two was a fun, scripted
video that has been inspired
by our fan base.
Now, I don't know how many
of you play Best Fiends,
but one of the things that
our community on social media
tell us quite a
lot is, actually,
don't download Best Fiends.
It's kind of addictive.
And a few people have said,
hey, I'm totally addictive.
Send me to Best Fiends rehab.
So we were kind of
inspired by that
and created a video
to that effect.
So if it's cool,
it's two minutes,
and we'd like to
premiere it today.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- There is a contagious
epidemic sweeping the nation.
It's not just in our
cities or our workplaces,
or even our homes.
It's in our hands.
- It's taken over my life.
- Once you start,
you can't stop.
- I don't know who I am anymore.
- Most people think Best
Fiends won't happen to them,
that it's simply harmless fun.
- I thought I could
just try it once.
- But soon, it
becomes an obsession.
- I wouldn't say I'm obsessed.
I'm spirited, passionate.
That's what's going on here.
- Some people we can help.
- Doc says I may never
use my thumbs again.
You always think it will happen
to someone else's family.
Look what it did to our Billy.
- Others require more
specialized treatment.
- I have finally
beaten level 256.
I'm a YouTube star.
- Course you are.
Start by recognizing the
warning signs, tiredness,
gamers thumbs, night
terrors, and sweaty eyes.
- It's so hot.
- In just seconds, anyone
can be playing Best Fiends.
After all, it's free to
download from Google Play.
- It took me about
a month to done it.
- One click, and
you may have begun
an obsession you can't stop.
Oh, hey, [INAUDIBLE].
Mo!
I was just talking
about Best Fiends.
Oh, no, no, I'm a doctor.
- Oh, of course
you are, Ms. Walsh.
Let's get you back into bed.
- No, it's Dr. Walsh!
No, I--
- Right now there is no
cure for Best Fiends.
My advice-- do not download
Best Fiends from Google Play.
Not once, not ever.
The world will be better for it.
Hm, [INAUDIBLE].
- Worst case of Best
Fiends I've ever seen.
Remember when she used
to be a doctor on TV?
- I still am!
[END PLAYBACK]
ANDREW STALBOW: That was cute.
So yeah, we're
launching that today.
We're promoting it in
our game and really
trying to use our
app as a platform
to promote our video as well.
And we're super excited about
it, so thanks for watching.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]